-Ryan and I are about to
face off in a new game
called "Spit Take Roulette."
Now, here's how this works.
We have 12 cups, okay?
Five of them are full of water.
The rest are full of random
liquids that are not water.
On your turn, you pick a cup
and you take a big sip.
If it's not water,
you have to swallow it.
If it is water, you get to spit
it in the other person's face.
First person --
-Why are we doing this?
I have no idea.
The First person to get
water spit in their face
three times loses.
We wrote this. I don't know why.
All right, let's put on our
safety glasses,
because safety is sexy.
Here we go.
-It is very sexy.
-Ryan, since you are our guest,
I will be going first.
-That's great.
-All right,
which one, which one?
-I'd go with this one.
-That one?
-Yeah. Why not?
Let's see what happens there.
-Mm-hmm-hmm-hmm.
Mm-hmm-hmm-hmm.
-Oh, God.
♪♪
Why would we do this?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Can we see that in slow motion?
Is there any way
that that exists?
-Oh! Open mouth. Open mouth.
Oh!
-Can you see anything?
-I can taste your
childhood right now.
That's just so disturbing.
-Oh, my God.
-All right.
-All right, please go for it.
-Okay, here we go,
here we go, here we go.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, that one --
That was a little violent.
That was a little violent
in that one.
Wow. It's 1-1.
These glasses
don't really work, do they?
It stings a little bit.
Okay, here we go.
Mm...which one?
-Yeah, that looks good.
All right.
♪♪
Oh, this is so...
Just gonna keep my mouth closed.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Foghorn blows ]
-Dude, that was a streamer,
that one.
Can we see what
that one looks like?
-Oh! Oh!
-Oh, mouth open again.
All right.
-Not exhibiting
cat-like reflexes.
-There are other things
besides water, I promise.
-I'm going with this one.
-I'm not looking.
-Okay.
♪♪
That's really good.
-Whoa!
Apple juice. Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Whew!
It's getting a little steamy.
♪♪
-No real scent to it.
That's interesting.
-Oh.
-It's actually -- I thought I
was going to get this.
It's actually Aviation Gin,
your gin.
That's actually fantastic.
-Hey, that's mine!
-That is your gin.
I thought --
-Yeah.
-By the way, whoo!
-Right?
-That's some good acting
right there.
I was like, "Why do we have to
use real gin, by the way?
Can't we just use Gatorade?"
-100%, dude.
-Hopefully there's not --
How many more of these are gins?
Because I have the rest of
the show to do.
Poor Rosie --
-Oh, wow.
-Poor Rosie Huntington-Whiteley.
-Fantastic.
-I'll be like,
"You're my favorite.
I love you so much."
Okay.
-All right. Here we go.
2-2.
-You sure you want that one?
-I want this one.
-You sure?
-Yep.
-Oh, good,
'cause it's orange juice, dude.
It's Gatorade!
♪♪
-Ahh! That's very nice.
-It was ginger ale.
[ Laughs ]
Probably Canada Dry.
Feeling good, feeling good!
Here we go!
Aren't you so happy
you did my show?
-Oh, man, come on. I'm hydrated.
It's really great.
Which one do you think, guys?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Don't help him!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh, man.
-Congrats on the movie, man.
-Thank you.
-In theaters May 10th.
-All right.
-Yeah, I'll be watching.
-[ Clears throat ]
-Oh!
-Tang. That tastes good.
-I forgot all about Tang.
-Astronaut juice.
-Yeah, I forgot all about Tang.
-They love it.
-I love it. How did we get Tang?
I don't even think
they make that anymore.
All right.
♪♪
You're smiling.
[ Laughs ]
-Gatorade.
-Wow! This is unbelievable.
-It's Gatorade.
-That was good.
-You almost acted like you were
throwing up in your mouth.
All right.
We're down to four right here.
-I mean, right?
One of these will be vomit.
I know you.
-I know one is pickle juice.
I know that.
-Ooh!
-I don't know which one.
I know -- it's gross.
♪♪
[ Both laugh ]
Oh, my goodness.
-Hmm.
-Really savor it.
Get as much saliva mixed in
as possible, by the way.
[Bleep]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-That is it! I am the champion!
[ Dinging ]
Ryan Reynolds, everyone!
Go see "Pokémon
Detective Pikachu" May 10th.
Rosie Huntington-Whiteley
joins us after the break!
Stick around!
♪♪
-♪ Don't even ask
how the high feel ♪
♪ How do I feel? ♪
♪ Like the sky feel ♪
♪ They come in sideways
like in "Seinfeld" ♪
♪ The grapes of wrath
intertwined ♪
♪ Vine still ♪
♪ I'm ill ♪
♪ Walking through a mine...♪